cinco años de incertidumbre está ya en
este jueves en masivas manifestaciones
los refugiados rojillas salieron a las
calles para conmemorar el 25 de agosto
de 2017 cuando más de 750.000 personas
de esta minoría musulmana tuvieron que
huir de mianmar para escapar de la
cruenta violencia de sus autoridades los
rohingya denuncian que fue genocidio de
nuestro hay una ballena hoy nos estamos
manifestando como en 2017 cuando el
ejército birmano mató a nuestra gente en
un genocidio mataron a mi esposo y a
otros los militares nos violaron luego
mataron a nuestros hijos arrojándolos al
fuego arrebatando los del regazo de las
madres marí marí murad y enormes argán
arafat más ahora queremos justicia
durante los últimos cinco años hemos
estado diciendo lo mismo a la gente del
mundo pero nadie nos escuchó hoy nos
estamos manifestando nuevamente solo
para que el mundo sepa que queremos
justicia dando un acto de sardá
desde el inicio de la persecución el
pueblo rojilla vive en campamentos de
refugiados en bangladesh en una
situación cada vez más precaria casi un
millón de personas más de la mitad
menores de edad se aglomeran en casas de
hojalata y bambú deben enfrentar las
constantes inundaciones en épocas de
monzón la creciente insalubridad y
también la inseguridad a raíz de bandas
armadas de tráfico de drogas y de
personas que crecen atravesadas por la
pobreza y la falta de oportunidades la
principal demanda de las rojillas volver
a su casa la mayoría del estado de rajin
en mianmar pero temen seguir indefensos
especialmente porque las autoridades
birmanas siguen impunes los
perpetradores de los crímenes
internacionales cometidos en mianmar
deben rendir cuentas la justicia para
las víctimas contribuirá a un futuro
político sostenible e inclusivo para el
país y su gente
el golpe de estado en mí al mar de
febrero de 2021 solo empeora la
situación y aleja el esperado retorno